chapter 3. why is I here
why is I here yeah it's really important
to say that we don't know and yet at the
same time we know that we exist
yeah and we know that because we're here
I'm in front of a microphone I'm next to
you I have my fingers and my toes and
that's all that really matters you know
I again like you said it's really
important to say that we don't know yes
so we're not looked at as the
all-knowing yeah so when you always have
a question you think of sky and Atlas no
no you want to think of you you want to
start investigating you and obviously if
you need a little helper you know a
little assistance this is what the
course is for exactly so we're not we're
not trying to not lend assistance but we
know that true Evolution happens from
within yes so nice yeah love that and so
then
um piggybacking on true Evolution comes
from within
the answer of I don't know
is actually liberating
because
you know that you exist you know that
you are which is so evident just via
direct experience right right now is
I am
I exist I feel existence I am existence
yeah right and so from there then you
can liberate anything else of well as we
say why is it here
I don't know we don't know
but we exist
and we don't need to then ask other
people yeah about why I is here yeah
yeah so I don't need to Outsource my
sovereignty or my will I don't need to
Outsource it to get someone else to tell
me why I is here yes so that yeah that's
and and that's also just the fun part I
feel like just being able to investigate
life like you know you know what they
say that you know kids are the most
enlightened you know they're closest to
God because the way they act they're
demeanor they always want to find out
they want to understand and as adults
we're boring we've lost that will to
want to understand more and we just
trust Google
which was Siri or whatever and um yeah
this is again this book is to bring you
back to being a child that's why it is
an adult children's book yes yeah so yes
yes and that's why so many of the greats
and even some of the most genius people
that have ever lived have always talked
about retaining their childlike
curiosity absolutely yeah and so
basically the child is the detective the
child is the investigator yeah and the
adult can sometimes be
uh oh I'm done investigating yeah I'm
good I know it I know I work my job I
have my my Concepts my ideas my
framework my lens of perception has
become ossified it's become solidified
and so now I'm quote done looking for
new ways of perceiving and that is you
could say your death
if you yeah if you're done looking for
new ways of perceiving if you're done
investigating you've died you've died
so investigate like a child investigate
like this is our creation and
investigate my man my lady investigate
um there's nothing more important like
we wrote there's nothing more important
and and then the the second core part of
this chapter that we wanted to get
across was
what changes when we see outside his eye
rather than John and I would just say
everything you you your reality is more
vast now there's more questions than
these answers that means that your
mundane life comes a little more mundane
you know now it's time to get out here
and understand what the hell let's get
answers to these questions we want
solutions to the the quarrels of the
world but we don't gain solutions to the
small things in our lives
so yeah how can we ever understand
what's out there if we don't understand
what's in here
yes and this question is also meant to
be a
a leading thread for you to follow
absolutely you follow this thread of
what changes when I see myself as I
rather than only my name yeah so if you
can first feel yourself as I and see
yourself in all as I and then and then
be loving about your unique label
at the same time simultaneously
simultaneously what will change
versus if you only knew yourself as your
label and thought of everyone else as
just their own separate labels yeah it's
like you live in a half-life
yes yes perfect it's likely you're
living a half-life so so have a whole
life by knowing yourself as I and then
just watch what would change when you
see everything as I and so we'll leave
it at that and we'll unpack it more
later
Beauty end of chapter three